Кліматично нейтральні автомобілі з 2035: що буде після
відмови від двигунів внутрішнього згоряння
Промова Штайнмаєра про ситуацію в країні:
дивіденди миру вичерпані
Повернення додому попри війну:
українські біженці повертаються на Батьківщину
В ефірі heute journal з Ґундулою Ґаузе
та Анною Ґеллінек.
Добрий вечір.
Автомобілі з двигуном внутрішнього згоряння
поступово будуть зняті з виробництва.
Тепер ми знаємо це напевно.
27 країн-членів ЄС
і Європейський парламент
дійшли згоди щодо заборони виробництва
дизельних та бензинових автомобілів
З 2035 року, тобто через 12 років.
Уся Європа планує повністю перейти на електромобілі?
Не зовсім. На бажання FDP уряд Німеччини
домовився про маленьку компромісну лазівку.
Через чотири роки варто ще раз перевірити,
чи не можна заправляти двигун внутрішнього згорання
синтетичним пальним.
Вже за мить ми поспілкуємося
з міністром транспорту Німеччини,
але спершу сюжет Лотара Беккера
про автомобілі майбутнього.
Відгадайте країну-виробника.
Ось так виглядає автомобіль майбутнього -
китайський седан преміум-класу,
який вже за кілька днів з'явиться і в Німеччині.
ET7 від NIO.
Це єдиний серійний автомобіль, який можна не заряджати,
а просто замінити розряджений акумулятор
усього за кілька хвилин.
Ми переконані, що зі змінним акумулятором
автомобіль набуває величезну перевагу
та, відповідно, дорожчає в ціні.
Це справді унікальна торговельна пропозиція.
Наша продукція не має аналогів. У нас своє бачення.
Підвищена вартість обумовлена тим, що в цих
автомобілях можна за п'ять хвилин замінити акумулятор,
тобто вам більше не доведеться чекати
20 хвилин, допоки акумулятор зарядиться.
Ця ідея не нова, робота над її втіленням
розпочалася 50 років тому.
Компанія «Mercedes Benz» продемонструвала подібну пробну
модель ще в 1972 році довівши, що акумулятор автомобіля
можна просто замінити, а довгі очікування
на зарядних станціях зовсім не обов'язкові.
У 1990-х роках з'являлося багато різних
гібридних та повністю електричних
тестових моделей автомобілів німецького виробництва.
У 2000-х у Японії продовжили дослідження
змінних акумуляторів.
Компанія «Renault» також брала участь у розробці
електромобіля, що швидко заряджається.
Подібні дослідження та створення тестових моделей завжди
віталися, проте на масове виробництво не наважувався ніхто.
Попри обережність та завбачливість корифеїв
авторинку, з'являлися дедалі нові компанії.
Передусім Tesla, над якою довго лише сміялися,
а зараз це один із найпотужніших виробників
електромобілів у світі.
Також тому, що компанія почала завчасно інвестувати у
власну інфраструктуру швидкого заряджання.
Саме завдяки новітнім технологіям Tesla лишила
німецьку автопромисловість далеко позаду.
Зараз просто створювати автомобілі недостатньо.
Німецька автомобільна промисловість зможе
запропонувати широкий спектр електромобілів для
будь-яких потреб. Але люди купуватимуть їх
лише за умови наявності електрозарядної інфраструктури,
яка дасть їм змогу заряджати автомобіль
у будь-який час і в будь-якому місці.
З цього погляду Брюссель доволі короткозорий.
Немає жодних зобов'язань перед країнами-учасницями,
які були б навіть віддалено достатніми.
Підтримка німецьких автовиробників
Європейським Союзом є недостатньою.
Як буде покриватися попит на електроенергію для
великої кількості електромобілів, як виробники
зможуть отримувати сировину, необхідну для
виробництва електромобілів, попри кризу та
незалежно від китайських постачальників?
Ми спостерігаємо жорстку глобальну конкуренцію
у промисловій політиці.
Як в Азії, так і в Америці
промисловість отримує значну фінансову
підтримку від держави.
Ключова проблема - довгі терміни постачань:
у Китаї, де виготовляються автомобілі «NIO»,
це вже давно не проблема.
Наразі термін очікування постачань становить 2-3 тижні.
Деталі для комплектування теж виготовлені в Німеччині.
Автомобілі були спроєктовані у Мюнхені.
Тут ми розробили їхній дизайн.
У нас також є філії у Сан-Хосе, США.
Розробка автомобілів або окремих частин
відбувається в Англії, в Оксфорді. Тоді як інноваційні
автомобілі без двигунів внутрішнього згоряння
вже з'являються на дорогах за кордоном,
автопромисловість Німеччини може лишитися далеко позаду.
З нами на зв'язку з Ландау-ін-дер-Пфальц
міністр транспорту Німеччини.
Доброго вечора, пане Віссінґу.
Добрий вечір.
З 2035 року фактично настане кінець для
автомобілів із двигунами внутрішнього згоряння в Європі.
Що це означатиме для німців,
які планують придбати автомобіль в наступні 10 років?
Ми на порозі великих трансформацій.
Електромобільність відграватиме центральну роль.
Але ще не на всі запитання, пов'язані з кліматично
нейтральною мобільністю, є відповіді.
Тому ми маємо лишатися відкритими
до нових технологій.
Відкритість до нових технологій у вашому розумінні
передбачає можливість використання
синтетичного, тобто електричного палива,
для заправки двигуна внутрішнього згоряння.
Ви досягли компромісу, що це питання буде
перерозглянуто у 2026 році. Навіщо?
Тому що нам потрібне синтетичне
або так зване електронне паливо.
У Європі сформувався певний автопарк,
який має стати екологічнішим.
Немає жодної переконливішої пропозиції,
аніж використовувати синтетичне паливо
задля екологічнішого використання вже наявних
автомобілів з двигунами внутрішнього згоряння у Європі.
Ми досі не знаємо, яку роль відграватиме
синтетичне паливо в майбутньому.
Тому нам безперечно необхідно забезпечити
таку можливість у Європі.
Для нас важливий кожен внесок у кліматично нейтральну
мобільність, ми не обмежуємося однією технологією.
Загальнонімецький автомобільний клуб(ADAC), який
не підозрюють у близькості до партії Зелених,
заявляє, що синтетичне паливо споживає занадто багато
енергії під час виробництва і зовсім не ефективне.
То навіщо ж на ньому зосереджуватися замість того,
щоб рухатися вперед з електромобілями?
Тому що у нас є флот, наприклад, який
також має стати кліматично нейтральним.
І ми не можемо використовувати двигуни внутрішнього
згоряння, які були продані мільйонами в Європі і які
досі зареєстровані, ми не можемо використовувати
електроприводи або переобладнати їх на електроприводи.
Cаме тому нам потрібні синтетичні види палива.
Вони потрібні нам у повітряному сполученні.
Вони потрібні нам для важкої техніки.
Вони потрібні нам у судноплавстві,
а також для нашого флоту.
І зараз не зрозуміло, за якою ціною їх
пропонуватимуть у майбутньому.
Саме тому цей варіант не можна відкидати, це
важливий внесок у кліматично нейтральну мобільність.
Нам потрібні всі технологічні рішення,
а не лише окремі з них.
Якщо ми хочемо здійснити якісний переворот у
вітчизняному автобудівництві,
Німеччині необхідно зробити більше для того,
щоб електромобілі можна було заряджати..
У Німеччині на кожні 711 автомобілів
припадає одна зарядна станція.
У Нідерландах їх трохи більше сотні.
Чому Німеччина не просувається вперед
у питанні зарядних станцій?
У цьому полягає відома проблема «курки і яйця»:
врешті-решт, розширення інфраструктури має
відбуватися швидше, ніж нарощування електромобілів.
Саме тому Кабінет Міністрів ухвалив
генеральний план розширення зарядної інфраструктури,
за допомогою якого ми розбудовуватимемо
загальнонімецьку мережу.
Нам потрібні станції швидкої зарядки
вздовж наших магістральних доріг.
І, звичайно, нам також потрібно більше
зарядних станцій у місцевих громадах.
З генеральним планом, який я презентував,
і який був схвалений урядом, ми зараз здійснюємо
саме те розширення, яке вкрай необхідне Німеччині.
І ми маємо це робити паралельно з нарощуванням
кількості електромобілів, які надходять на ринок.
До речі, ми робимо це в Німеччині за допомогою
цифрових технологій, заснованих на даних, і
у такий спосіб також показуємо приклад
іншим європейським країнам.
Німеччина довгий час була світовим лідером у
виробництві двигунів внутрішнього згоряння.
Тепер, коли епоха лідерства добігає кінця,
постачальники автомобільної продукції вже занепокоєні
втратою майже 300 тис. робочих місць упродовж
наступних кількох років.
Що чекає на німецький автопром?
Необхідно розглядати це питання з усією серйозністю.
Саме тому має залишатися відкритим і питання про те,
чи не має двигун внутрішнього згоряння
зрештою майбутнього з синтетичним паливом.
Ми також знаємо, що електромобілі дорогі, і ми знаємо,
що літій для акумуляторів
недоступний в необмеженій кількості.
І тому є сенс тримати питання двигуна внутрішнього
згоряння, який може працювати кліматично нейтрально
на синтетичному паливі, відкритим.
Навіщо від чогось відмовлятися без необхідності,
коли так багато питань про майбутнє нез'ясовані.
Це недалекозора політика.
Саме тому для нас було надзвичайно важливо, щоб ця
можливість зберігалася і була
затвердженою на європейському рівні.
З нами на зв'язку був міністр транспорту.
Щиро дякуємо.
Із закликом продовжувати використовувати синтетичне
паливо, а також розвивати електромобільність.
Вітання Ландау-ін-дер-Пфальц.
Дякую.
Ескалація - не вихід, але й відступ теж.
Президент Франк-Вальтер Штайнмаєр
виступив із промовою до німецького народу.
Останнім часом критика президента
ставала дедалі гучнішою,
адже він досі не висловлював своєї позиції
щодо війни в Україні.
Ті, хто очікував разючих змін у поглядах чи навіть
каяття від політика, який майже 15 років відповідав
за відносини Німеччини з Росією, були розчаровані.
Тим не менш, він чітко сказав: «Німеччина переживає
важкі часи, настає епоха зустрічних вітрів».
Патриція Відемеєр розповість про промову і реакцію
на неї детальніше.
На цю промову чекали довго,
як і довго працювали над нею.
Свою промову Штайнмаєр розпочав
із вражень після візиту до України
та спогадів про день початку війни.
Виття сирен, темний дим над Києвом,
той ранок був направду страшним.
Усі ці події ніби залізли мені під шкіру і ознаменували
собою остаточну, гірку поразку
багаторічних політичних зусиль, зокрема й моїх,
щоб запобігти саме цьому жахливому моменту.
24 лютого стало днем зміни епох.
Він не захотів знову просити вибачення за
його тісні зв'язки з Росією у минулому.
Його візит до Києва на початку тижня
став чітким сигналом відмежування від Росії.
Штайнмаєр заявив, що Путін
порушив не лише правила гри,
а й знищив європейську безпеку.
Якщо подивитися на Росію сьогодні,
то не залишається місця для старих мрій.
Наші країни сьогодні протистоять одна одній.
Тим, хто активно закликає до мирних переговорів,
він дав чітку відмову.
У кожної свідомої людини є воля. Але насправді
перед лицем зла доброї волі недостатньо.
Серед присутніх - новий український посол,
якого особливо вразила саме ця частина виступу.
Настрій, якого від його попередника
Мельника, мабуть, і не почули б.
Для мене особисто це була
промова на підтримку України.
Він закликав Німеччину та всіх громадян
підтримати Україну, допомогти їй.
Тут я відчув себе українцем та європейцем.
Наприкінці Штайнмаєр налаштовував
німців на труднощі у майбутньому
та наполягав на обмеженнях
та скромному способі життя.
На нас чекають важкі та суворі часи.
Дивіденди мирного часу вичерпано,
для Німеччини розпочинається
епоха протистояння зустрічному вітру.
Політик підкреслив, що тепер йдеться
про згуртованість бідних та багатих,
молодшого та старшого поколінь,
міст і сіл, заходу та сходу.
До того ж потрібно посилити зусилля
у боротьбі зі зміною клімату.
Чесно кажучи, мене непокоїть те,
що це завдання людства
відходить на задній план.
Зміна клімату
не припиняється через війну в Україні.
Аудиторія налаштована позитивно.
Для мене це була велична промова,
в якій все було названо своїми іменами,
що зараз ми увійшли
в епоху протистояння зустрічному вітру.
Маю зізнатися, що для мене це історична промова.
Я сприйняла цю промову насамперед
як дуже сильну промову.
Але, на жаль, дуже мало говорилося про молодь.
Але чи була це дійсно історична промова
з пам'ятною фразою, як у деяких його попередників?
8 травня був днем звільнення.
Німеччина має просуватися вперед.
Наше серце відкрите, та наші можливості обмежені.
Іслам - це також частина Німеччини.
Політолог Реммеле вважає,
що Штайнмаєру не вистачило
власного визнання провини
щодо відносин із Росією, а також запалу.
За змістом це дуже гарна промова, тому
що вона була чесною,
тому що вона відкрила епоху
протистояння зустрічному вітру,
а чи запам'ятається вона, покаже час.
Я б хотіла, щоб вона була більш пафосною,
тоді її краще сприймуть громадяни.
Однак у залі її сприйняли дуже добре.
Наше завдання - зміцнити все, що нас об'єднує.
Тож зробімо це. Щиро дякую.
І хто знає, можливо саме
останнє речення закарбується у пам'яті.
А я передаю слово
Ґундулі, яка розкаже про інші новини
та ще одну промову.
Та жорстку критику,
яку висловив голова партії CSU Зедер
щодо роботи уряду.
За його словами, уряд «світлофорної» коаліції, мабуть,
один з найслабших урядів Німеччини.
За рік до виборів до земельного парламенту Баварії
на з'їзді партії CSU він сказав,
що уряд перевантажений енергетичною кризою.
Особливо Зедер критикував Зелених.
Ви не кліматична партія,
ви все та ж стара ліва антиядерна партія.
Постійно виступають одні й ті ж люди,
Клаудія Рот плаче, Юрген Тріттін кричить.
Не це потрібно Німеччині, любі друзі.
Більше про з'їзд партії CSU
дивіться у програмі «heute journal up:date»,
де завтра чекатимуть на лідера
партії CDU Фрідріха Мерца.
За словами президента постійної комісії
з вакцинації Мертенса, нині COVID-19 -
це ендемічна вірусна інфекція.
Значна частина населення уже одужала,
вакцинувалася або й те, й інше,
як він стверджує в інтерв'ю Баварського радіо.
На корону, як і на грип,
хворітимуть ще цілі покоління.
Тому важливо захистити тих, хто в зоні ризику
за допомогою вакцинації
чи засобів індивідуального захисту.
Невідомі вчинили підпал
у притулку в місті Бауцен,
де планували розмістити біженців.
Спочатку розбили вікна, а згодом почалася пожежа.
Чотири людини, що перебували вночі
всередині, залишилися неушкодженими.
Міністр внутрішніх справ Саксонії Шустер
назвав причину підпалу - ксенофобія.
Управління державної поліції
перевіряє можливі політичні підґрунтя злочину.
В Ірані тривають антиурядові протести
попри постійні акти насилля з боку поліції.
У Захедані, за словами очевидців,
силовики стріляли в мітингувальників.
Нині начальника поліції звільнено.
Повідомляють, що він,
як і місцеві представники духовенства,
критикував жорстку політику уряду.
На Ненсі Пелосі, лідерку демократів у
Палаті представників США,
вочевидь, здійснено замах.
Злочинець проник в її будинок у Сан-Франциско,
напав та поранив чоловіка у той час, як її не було вдома.
Злочинця затримано.
Обставини злочину наразі з'ясовують.
Міжнародне агентство з атомної
енергії, МАГАТЕ, планує цього
тижня відрядити інспекторів в Україну.
Експерти перевірятимуть звинувачення Росії про те,
що Україна нібито планує застосувати «брудну бомбу»
з радіоактивним зарядом.
Голова МАГАТЕ Гроссі пояснив, що мета місії -
здійснити перевірку двох місць.
Раніше Україна й Росія
висловлювалися за проведення експертизи.
Переходимо до новин з України.
І вдень, і вночі російська армія атакує
країну дронами та ракетами.
Єдина тактика Росії - це терор, -
про це наголосив Президент України
Володимир Зеленський
у своєму нічному відеозверненні.
І все ж українські родини повертаються
в зони бойових дій,
тому що їм важко розлучатися
з батьками, братами
та своїми домівками.
Наш кореспондент Дара Гасанзаде
познайомився в Одесі з такою родиною
і супроводжував сім'ю в її рідне місто Миколаїв,
де й досі тривають бої.
Вони напрочуд радісні, й ця радість
передається тим, хто поряд.
Родина Лютовичів немало пережила:
шість місяців сім'я була розділеною,
матір Юлія та син Юрій на початку березня
виїхали через Молдову до Німеччини.
Хлопець закінчив навчальний рік онлайн
і навіть вчив німецьку.
Принаймні: «Трішки!»
Тепер вони хочуть почати нове життя в Одесі -
посеред війни.
Юрій мріє стати режисером анімаційних фільмів.
Він анімує малюнки
травмованих дітей біженців з України.
Діти бачать все це своїми очима.
Наприклад, вони малюють злі танки.
І раптом дитячі картинки починають рухатися.
Ідея належить колишній сусідці -
вона працювала дитячим психологом
і піклувалася про травмованих українських дітей.
Перебування біженцями в Німеччині
було схоже на казку - про це розповідає Юрій.
Там їх прийняли надзвичайно дружні люди,
і вони й досі не розуміють,
чому він та його матір
захотіли повернутися назад,
у країну в стані війни.
А Юрій не зрозумів, чому німці так хвилюються
і бояться.
Приїжджайте в Україну і відчуйте,
як це - жити без страху.
Або навпаки: відчуйте, що означає справжній страх.
Вперше після виїзду з країни вони повертаються
до Миколаєва, де Юрій виріс.
Місто постійно під обстрілами,
їхній будинок також постраждав.
Тепер вони хочуть на власні очі побачити,
що залишилося від їхнього дому.
Цілою залишилась лише одна шибка.
Шрапнель влучив в будинок.
Вони так хочуть повернутись.
Проте поки Миколаїв під обстрілами російської артилерії,
немає сенсу
відновлювати рідний будинок Юрія.
Здається, ніби все, як і раніше.
Кухня, кімнати, сходи.
Але більше немає електрики, води та вікон.
Спочатку я думав, мій кіт тут би більше не жив.
Але тут більше ніхто не живе.
Рідний дім Юрія. Скільки років
тут вирувало життя. Життя його сім'ї.
Зараз тут порожньо. Тепер це ніби будинок з привидами.
Ілон Маск - геніальний підприємець з величезним его.
Успішний виробник Tesla і конструктор
ракетних двигунів «Space-X»
не з сором'язливих.
Американський мільярдер
так обґрунтував придбання соціальної мережі «Twitter»:
«Я зробив це, щоб допомогти людству, яке я люблю».
Однак Twitter – це мережа,
яка більше наповнена ненавистю, аніж любов'ю.
Тепер виникає питання, для чого вона
ексцентричному Маску.
Побоюються, що він може
розширити ще більше межі того,
що можна сказати.
Репортаж Беньяміна Даніеля з Вашингтона.
Коли Ілон Маск рано вранці написав у своєму Twitter,
що птаха випустили,
реакція ЄС не забарилася.
Європейський комісар Тьєррі Бретон написав
у відповідь:
«В Європі птах літатиме за правилами ЄС».
Я певною мірою зловтішаюся,
що Ілон Маск пішов на це.
Йому доведеться відповісти ЄС і
буде цікаво спостерігати,
чи сумісні його погляди «Дикого Заходу»
з радше консервативним поглядом ЄС,
коли йтиметься про правила свободи слова
в інтернеті.
Вже вчора Маск змінив свій опис профілю
на «Chief Twit» (Головний у Twitter),
що дослівно перекладається як
«Головний дурень».
Маск любить таку неоднозначність.
Зокрема щодо однозначності, то це
його придбання соцмережі після довгих вагань,
де він написав:
Я придбав Twitter, бо це важливо
для майбутнього нашої цивілізації
мати спільний цифровий ринок,
де можна буде екологічно
обговорювати різні теми, не вдаючись до насильства.
У кінці квітня керівник Tesla підтвердив
придбання концерну за 44 млрд доларів.
Потім він захотів відмовитись від цієї покупки.
Twitter подав до суду і до початку процесу
обидві сторони
все ж таки погодили придбання.
Перше, що зробив Маск на посаді керівника, це
одразу звільнив кілька топменеджерів,
а також попередніх генерального директора,
фінансового директора,
а також головного юрисконсульта.
Найбагатша людина світу - тепер також
власник однієї з найбільших соцмереж.
Багато хто вважає це небезпечним.
Тому що Маск неодноразово
підкреслював, що хоче значно розширити
межі свободи слова.
Він свято вірить у те,
що сам називає свободою слова,
а саме, що має бути менше модерації та видалень
дописів,
які поширюють дезінформацію.
Це може мати величезний вплив
на роль Twitter у нашому суспільстві.
Звичайно, це придбання
також має і політичний контекст.
Так, наприклад, Маск оголосив, що
хоче знову розблокувати акаунт Дональда Трампа.
Спостерігачів хвилюють й інші аспекти.
Маск виглядає неймовірно наївним,
коли йдеться про зовнішню політику.
Він весь час робить якісь пропозиції,
які, на думку експертів, зовсім не мають сенсу
в зовнішній політиці.
Іноді ці пропозиції вигідні для Росії чи Китаю.
Маск має великий завод
у Шанхаї, і це підстава для побоювань,
що він може об'єднати свої політичні переконання
з підприємницькими інтересами.
Отже, це угода, яка багато в чому
спричиняє велике занепокоєння.
Тепер, коли Twitter став приватною
власністю, Нью-Йоркська фондова біржа
вже припинила обіг акцій.
Ці акції зняли з обігу в Нью-Йорку,
а інші технічні гіганти
перевантажують фінансові ринки:
акції Meta, Amazon і Google падають.
Франку Бетмане,
навіть американські акції технічних гігантів
не можуть протистояти слабким ринкам.
Це тиждень, щоб забути
великі технологічні концерни,
які завжди були відомі до сьогодні.
Тризначні мільярдні суми зникли в повітрі,
тому що ціни на акції падають.
Спочатку акції Microsoft і
материнської компанії «Google Alphabet».
Але найгірше становище у
холдингової компанії «Facebook Meta».
Імперія Цукерберга всього за три дні втратила
30% ринкової вартості.
А акції Amazon
від учора впали врешті-решт до 20%.
Такі коливання на фондовому ринку спричинені
передусім поганими показниками бізнесу
у поєднанні, що ще важливіше, з похмурими
перспективами.
Як в Alphabet, Microsoft, так і в Amazon.
Найбільший у світі інтернет-магазин передусім
розчарував, тим що значно занижує очікування
щодо різдвяних продажів. Незвично.
Такого ще не було з концернами США, що
швидко розвиваються.
Проте тепер Amazon також переймається
через інфляцію та економічний спад.
Так само, як Apple.
Генератор доходу iPhone здебільшого слабшає.
Також компанія з яблуком
тепер попереджає про зниження
продажів у поточному кварталі.
В Apple справи йдуть все ще непогано,
порівняно з інвесторами.
Дуже дякую, Франку. Прошу.
Варто додати, що німецька економіка
у третьому кварталі несподівано вийшла в плюс.
За першими оцінками Федерального відомства
статистики,
попри усі кризи, плюс 0,3 процентні пункти
у порівнянні з попереднім кварталом.
Хвилюватися варто передусім через високу інфляцію,
яка зросла з 10% у вересні до 10,4% у жовтні.
Новий антирекорд.
Через тарифний конфлікт німецької металевої та
електропромисловості
профспілка «IG Metal» оголосила від опівночі
попереджувальні страйки на кількох підприємствах.
Пропозицію роботодавців щодо одноразової
виплати в 3000 євро без оподаткування
плюс ще невизначеної додаткової виплати
протягом понад 30 місяців
у багатьох відділах профспілки відхилили.
Вони вимагають підвищення заробітної плати на 8%
на термін більше як рік.
До новин футболу. У Бундеслізі розпочався 12-ий
ігровий день
вечірньою зустріччю бременського ФК «Вердер»
з«Гертою».
Матч закінчився перемогою «Вердера» з рахунком 1:0.
Померла одна з найбільших легенд американського
рок-н-ролу.
Джері Лі Льюїсу - The Killer, як він сам себе називав -
було 87 років.
Він прославився
своєю швидкою грою на фортепіано різними
частинами тіла.
У 50-х роках він випустив свій найпопулярніший хіт
«Great Balls of Fire».
Дикі виступи зробили йому імідж Bad Boy
(поганого хлопця),
але водночас одного з останніх представників
старої школи рок-н-ролу.
Це все на сьогодні.
Дивіться далі heute show з Олі Вельке.
А о 00:15 heute journal up:date
з Ханною Ціммерман.
А ми побачимося завтра.
Гарного вечора і до побачення.
Добрий вечір, з вами прогноз погоди.
А почнемо ми сьогодні
з рекордів жовтня.
Найвища денна температура 30,9°C зафіксована
у Мюлльгаймі, у Баден-Вюртемберзі.
Найнижча нічна температура була у Верніґероде,
в Гарці, - 20,5 °C
Ці рекорди ми сьогодні не побили.
Проте Мюлльгайм залишається лідером
найвищої позначки 28,7 °C
за останні десять днів жовтня.
У рейтингу найвищих температур Фрайбург, Еммендінген,
Бухенбах,
Баден-Вюртемберг та Ґарзебах у Саксонії
з температурними показниками понад 25°C.
Загалом літню погоду сьогодні зафіксували
більш ніж 25 станцій Німеччини.
Сьогоднішня ніч буде не такою теплою, як попередня.
У Бад-Гарцбурзі температура становила 19,9°C.
Але і цієї ночі вона зупиниться на двоцифровій позначці.
Лише на південному сході температура опуститься
до 7°C.
Тут буде ясно, а тут - туманно,
на решті території очікується мінлива хмарність.
Завтра вранці на півночі буде хмарно.
У центрі також очікуються дощі.
Сонячна погода пануватиме на півдні та на півночі
гірського масиву.
І це саме той фактор, який зумовлює легкий
південний вітер
та денні температури.
У такий спосіб завтра температура знову підніметься
до 26°C в горах та на південному заході.
На півночі через туман буде прохолодніше,
але все ще тепло.
Неділя також обіцяє бути теплою та сонячною.
Лише на початку наступного тижня температура
поступово опускатиметься.
До побачення.